[Music]
the conference on the future of europe
is in full swing
europe's biggest ever exercise in
participatory democracy saw 200 more
europeans of all ages and backgrounds
meet in parliament's home in strasbourg
for the second eu citizens panel to
discuss issues that matter to them
europe democrats
this time they discussed eu values
rights security and the rule of law
citizens shared their ideas about
strengthening democracy in the eu
suggestions included engaging voters by
better informing them about european
elections bringing eu institutions
closer and making them more relevant and
ways to foster a european spirit
that's where the democratic
part of it comes in that it's absolutely
essential
that the people have as much power as
possible
they also discussed how to protect
democracy from outside interference
as well as group discussions they broke
into smaller workshops to examine issues
including ways of bringing the eu closer
to citizens how to improve security
ensuring member states respect the rule
of law and how to boost equality for all
for example
[Music]
20 members from each european citizens
panel will join the conference plenary
as full members
proposals made by the panels will help
shape the conference's recommendations
expected in spring 2022
[Music]
you